básicamente es contra el estado
venezolano y las instituciones por los
hechos ocurridos en el año 2017 por
actos del que ellos consideran que se
cometió represión y porque hubo inacción
de parte de las instituciones como lo
adelantaba desde el 2018 venezuela viene
de enfrentar enfrentando examen
preliminar en el que se determinó que
por lo menos
44 tipos de crímenes que están
sancionados o castigados por el estatuto
de roma se cometieron en el país entre
ellos podemos nombrar el encarcelamiento
sus torturas violación violación sexual
persecución por motivos políticos hay
que recordar que desde
distintas organizaciones no
gubernamentales vienen denunciando este
atropellos
esto relacionado con las manifestaciones
el año 2017 y los encarcelamientos y
hasta el día de hoy
contabilidad
252 presos por personas detenidas por
razones políticas entonces básicamente
para concluir una investigación que va
en contra del estado venezolano y sus
inicios